HE'S HAD --
>> Mark: THAT WAS NO
BIG NIGHTS, SO HAS
REMEMBER THE PLAYOFFS LAST  THI
RIGHT HERE.
>> Mark: THIS GUY RIGHT HERE IS
DOING SOME DF LATE.
AND ANOTHER BIG ONE TONIGHT.
ABSOLUTELY OUTST THIS SEASON.
HERE IS LUKASCORER.
AND TONIGHT ISFRIENDS, SOMETHI
SHOW.
OH, MY. Derek: THEY'RE CALL MEG.
PEOPLE ARE CALLING
MISSEDk: WELL THE MAVERICK
RECORD FOR POINTS
THEY'RE CHASING WITH ZUBAC.
>> THERE
CLOSING OUT THAT TIME,
EVERYTHING IS DLY,
FRUSTRATINGLY, HE CAL REGGIE WA
OUT.
>> Mark: TWO MOR THREES AT THE
FIRST HALF AND NOW HE'S GOING TO
THE CUP.
>> Derek: HE'S DANCINLUKA, ABSO
THE PLACE ON
REMAINING IN THE THIRD.
THAT'S A 15 FOUL.
>> Derek: TAKE A LOOK AT BRUNSOS
TO BE.
AND WITH A GUYONE MORE TWICE.
TO JOIN THAT WE JUST GET THE
NOTE, THEY WENT 11 FOR 11.
THAT HELPS THEM TO A 112-105 WIN
ON THE LOS ANGELES CLIPPERS
FIRST TIME THIS SEASON.
DALLAS IS TEN GAMES OVER 500,
AND 33 AND 23, AND THE MAN OF
THE HOUR, THE HIT MAKER, THE
RECORD BREAKER, LUKA DONCIC,
WITH 51 POINTS TONIGHT, THE
HIGHEST SCORING